oi amigos do facebook hoje aí alex
ronaldo você e eu tudo ótimo tudo muito
bom na vida de bacana a não ser uma
coisa está acontecendo agora gente
quatro sap e um dia pra cá ele atualizou
e agora ele mostra quando a pessoa olhou
a sua mensagem que antigamente era assim
você sabe quando você manda mensagens e
whatsapp aparece um risquinho quer dizer
que ela foi enviada algum lugar no
espaço ela fui quando aparece dois dias
quinta e já foi entregue à chegou no seu
lado outra pessoa só que você não sabe
se a pessoa tinha visto não tinha como
você saber se a pessoa realmente olhou
sua mensagem então que acontece você se
num dia você criar uma realidade falsa
na sua cabeça que a pessoa não tinha
visto essa mensagem com certeza não
levou a não não viu não se esqueceram
mais o índice você mandou natal de 2012
meu amigo mundo é assim as pessoas se
esquecem das coisas ainda não viu não
pegou células que se relaciona campo
onde esteja o nome 12 só vai dormir
quinza que enviar cinco horas da tarde é
que sou visualizou a tabela nove horas
da noite
mas talvez não na canon não quis falar
combina teerã não quer falar coerano
kaká pessoal tá feia a pessoa esquece
acontecer você filho dias e botar sua
cabeça a pessoa não viu para você ficar
bem com você mesmo agora usar por você
enviou mensagem a pessoa se a pessoa
tiver visualizar a mensagem
a sec efe caso que é isso aí satanás ela
se fé causando a escória que antigamente
não se ilude que a pessoa não tinha
visto a mensagem dilma sabe joga na sua
cara e esfrega sim na sua carta a pessoa
não quer falar com vocês e manda
mensagem a pessoa é assim fica azul ea
pessoa não responder a um ataque à sua
casa então que já não não tá em 2016 que
estavam em que ele fale com gostei e
fiquei tão triste tão tristes vaca é
boato manda mensagem a pessoa negócio
que casou rolar com e trocou ver e
passar por cima não viu porque tu fazes
rosado já não basta ficar o relógio
quando 3g tá ruim né
não me botado pega na cara das pessoas
que ninguém quer conversar com você
agora só está atualizando daqui um pouco
vai começar a aparecer as sete últimas
pessoas que visitaram eu prefiro tomar
comissionados aparece um bode pop agora
se mostra traz com que a outra pessoa
está conversando e nino cabeça e rola
também que a paula um pau está
conversando com fernandinho 27
centímetros
o ato faz a gente nesse momento acho que
não está acontecendo o enem fosse eu
pergunto muito isso você vai fazer o
enem
não só porque porque eu não preciso de
ninguém
ae
a mãe tá aqui mãe obrigado também a cena
já não achei nenhum ela finge de onde
veio e eu fico já que ela é uma pessoa
que lê se deixar a pessoa leva marmita
passou e passa três horas
o ator foi renovada obrigado a cesta
básica consegue capturar cinco melhores
grades não satisfeito em levar o ecca
toninho para fazer a prova a pessoa leva
roupas salgado ao gent sangue a outra se
concentrando atrás descrevem o do
satanás chocolate em uma coisa maior
dificuldade enfim quem vai fazer o enem
amanhã é que hoje está fazendo para
saber como chegaram a fazer o enem
amanhã é muito boa sorte pra você mas
estamos fazendo média espino direito que
todo mundo quer ser advogado mec ninguém
pedreiro ninguém quer ser não vai fazer
nem que eu já fiz sobre ele e passei pra
quem não sabe já passei por curso de
auxiliar de secretaria de ensino a minha
mãe a mexer no fez a gente só levei pra
vocês que dia 22 agora tem show em são
luís no maranhão ingresso no doutor em
ingresso lá no rio poty hotel tá
quem quiser ainda corre a etapa piloto
vendeu 700 no dia 29 em campina grande
na paraíba no dia 8 de dezembro em
manaus tudo você precisa saber sobre
stand ataque na descrição do vídeo edson
luiz corre o doutor ingresso no rio poty
hotel de compra quer de campina grande
corre na loja hattori lá no centro e com
seu ingresso e que é de manaus correm no
teatro manauara na bilheteria e contra a
igreja quer que você comece aqui embaixo
que você mais gosta no enem o que você
mais odeia todo mundo comentando isso
embaixo e depois gente no instagram aqui
na descrição do vídeo tá no meu twitter
também o meu facebook a minha página
para você curtir a minha página no
facebook onde discutiria para o facebook
se sentar por enquanto tem show ontem
curto valer é nóis
ainda cabe